welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Jessica Weiss assistant professor of
political science and a research fellow
at the Macmillan Center at Yale
University her research interests
include Chinese politics and
international relations nationalism and
social protest before joining the Yale
faculty she founded faces the forum for
American Chinese exchange at Stanford
University she teaches courses on anti
Americanism in world politics Chinese
foreign policy and State Society
relations in post now China today we'll
talk with her about her recent paper
powerful patriots anti-foreign protests
and authoritarian regimes welcome
professor Weiss thank you for having me
so let's talk about the argument you put
forth in your paper
tell us about it well in the paper which
is drawn from an excerpt of my larger
book manuscript I argue that
authoritarian leaders like China's have
strategic incentives to allow
anti-foreign protesters to say popular
demonstrations against foreign
governments and the arguments a little
bit counterintuitive the idea is that
even though protests are risky and have
the potential to turn against the
government and spiral out of control
governments like China's actually find
that these protests are useful in terms
of generating diplomatic bargaining
leverage so that even though protests
are risky it's that risk and the
difficulty of reining them in once they
begin that give leaders sort of domestic
political reasons to claim then on the
international stage that look we're
really here in a corner if we're going
to reach an agreement you the foreign
government need to cut us some slack
okay and what drew you to write this
paper what was your inspiration well in
2005 there were a series of
anti-japanese protests that broke out in
cities across China and it seemed at the
time that Western observers didn't have
let's say a unified view of what was
going on there was a lot of controversy
in particular there are two common views
one suggested that the government had
manufactured these protests either as a
way to rally the population around the
Chinese government to provide citizens
with sort of a safety valve to release
their grievances of whatever sort but
then from a completely opposite view
others suggested that these protests
were actually sort of a spontaneous
eruption of legitimate grievances and
which were quite dangerous to the
government that they actually rather
than being a safety valve could actually
turn against the government if it were
seen as being too weak and defending the
nation's interests so it was clear from
that particular episode which I which I
analyzed in this paper that there was a
gap in our understanding of what these
protests meant and particularly what
they what their implications were for
China's foreign relations okay and let's
talk about your methodology how did you
collect the data for the paper
well mostly I rely upon interviews and a
close reading of Chinese internet
websites I spent over a year in China
living in Beijing doing my field
research and it was clear through these
interviews with nationalist activists
protest organizers participants internet
forum managers Foreign Ministry
officials even a policeman that there
was a pattern that this was not an
isolated incident these 2005
anti-japanese protests and it was clear
that although the Chinese government had
allowed protests nationalist protests in
some cases in 2005 but also following
the u.s. bombing of the Chinese Embassy
in Belgrade in 1999 the Chinese
government had also on a number of
occasions actually restrained students
and others from taking to the streets
such as in 2001 when a US spy plane
collided with a Chinese fighter jet
causing the Chinese plane to ditch into
the sea and the
died you might have expected in fact
some suggested that there were protests
but in fact the Chinese government
prevented protests from occurring and
told the official media to turn down
their rhetoric in covering that incident
similarly on the issue of Taiwan an
issue of great concern to Chinese
nationalists and in the news today
there haven't been to date any protests
in China over the issue of Taiwan and
Taiwan independence so this sort of
created for me a puzzle that I uncovered
as I looked further into the background
of the 2005 protests just two years ago
in the lead up to the Olympics there
were a series of anti French protests so
again there's sort of multi headed
nationalism in China and I think it's is
it a little understood but it's
certainly there's a lot of material out
there and online in Chinese but also
foreign capitals pay great attention so
I looked at a lot of Japanese newspapers
as well
I interviewed Japanese and American
officials throughout the course of my
research I'm curious were you able to
talk to any Chinese officials or was
that not possible just in terms to get
their feedback possibly I did talk to a
number of Chinese officials in different
settings sometimes they would be
visiting United States and I'd have a
chance to talk with them sometimes I've
visited them in this there's a Starbucks
next to the foreign ministry in Beijing
so sometimes I would see them there by
and large they were very open to talking
with me I really in fact you know many
cases they're looking to sort of
showcase China in a good light and part
of that is interacting with the Chinese
I was aware American academics and
others who were interested in the study
of China okay great
why is it important to look at
authoritarian regimes like China an
international conflict well it's funny I
should ask because you know maybe 50
years ago people would talk about
autocracies as having
advantages because they're relatively
opaque it's hard to know what's exactly
going on inside them and by contrast
people with lament the inability of
democracies to conduct foreign policy in
sort of a sort of efficient manner there
is always compromise and negotiations
that would go on before the country
could articulate its foreign policy but
recently scholarship is swung in the
other direction and people have
increasingly touted the advantages of
democracy that that same openness and
giving democracies advantages and all
sorts of things like concluding trade
agreements winning Wars fighting on the
battlefield all sorts of things the
advantages that have been attributed to
democracies and scholarship on the
behavior of autocracy Zin international
relations and international conflict has
in recent years only begun to pick up
and but in this context I the argument
that I put forward essentially levels
the playing field between autocratic
states like China and democratic states
the United States so the argument that I
put forward basically says that if you
could imagine say a democrat an autocrat
sitting at a table negotiating
traditionally you would some might say
that the the Democrat the president of
the Prime Minister could say to the his
autocratic counterpart look Congress has
spoken I've pinned basically I don't
have any flexibility so if we're going
to reach a deal you the autocrat have to
give way and what I'm suggesting is that
the autocrat may not face elections but
nonetheless with mobs and the streets
you can say well you may have Congress
but look at me I've got mobs and we as
we know that the the consequences of
being voted out of office are far less
than perhaps the consequences of the mob
storming the palace gates and
potentially throwing the dictator into
exile or something much worse sure let's
talk about some of the conclusions you
reach in your paper well in the paper
I suggest that the anti-japanese
protests of 2005 we're an effective part
of China's diplomatic strategy to
undermine Japan's bid for
membership on the UN Security Council
and in doing so the Chinese were able to
mount a campaign particularly persuading
those in the region particularly the
United States and nations in Southeast
Asia from tempering their public support
for Japan's bid to be a permanent member
of the Security Council okay and finally
and doing the research for your paper
what was one of the most surprising
things you found well you know people
often assume that because China is an
autocratic state that the people are
more or less fed what the government
wants them to hear there's a sense in
which they aren't particularly
well-informed about foreign affairs and
politics in general and I actually found
that to be absolutely not the case and
in fact Chinese citizens whether it's
you know your students and universities
or you know they're notorious Beijing
taxi cab drivers they know a lot in fact
they I would wager that they know more
about international relations than sort
of their American equivalents and so
even though there's may perhaps less
space for political discourse
nevertheless the amount of information
in their knowledge of world affairs is
really quite striking interesting thank
you very much for being here with us
today and sharing some of your research
you're welcome for more information
about professor Weiss and her work
please visit our website at Yale edu
backslash Macmillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Centre for International and
area studies at Yale
you